an know difficult event for you but
everything that finishes well it's much
more pleasant to take home a victory for
you in the last round how are you
feeling right now give us your
assessment of this competition for
you uh competition uh in overall of
course I'm not happy with my result and
I lost four games in a row and very
happy to win in last round even if I I
don't look like happy it's always good
to finish on good
absolutely results yeah and losing like
four games was so frustrating especially
like yesterday I had winning position
versus U Karissa
congratulations I'm very happy for her
and but still I tried to win yesterday
and missing like Queen C5 which like my
husband says it was winning for me after
Queen C5 yesterday absolutely yes and
you've had a good year so far in terms
of results Great result at the Ken cup
sure
less great result in this one but what's
next for you an
know uh I don't have probably I would
like to play like World rapid and Blitz
championship and like usually I have
good results in Blitz and I hope to
train with proper training I finally can
I don't know get a medal or something
well I don't know even if this event
will take place where like every year
I'm playing and this is probably going
to be next result next next tournament
for me absolutely it's uh that that
tournament we never know exactly where
it's going to be when it's going to be
and then it's announced a couple of
weeks before Anna thank you very much
for joining us we'll see you in the next
tournament here in St
Louis yeah thank you and uh no